I was disclaiming every single thing  that my mom did instead of just stating  the reality or how I felt about it it  was I was more concerned with how I how  to keep my mom looking good than I was  with expressing my true emotional  reality okay I think I'm having an aha  moment Tell Me Maybe it's protectiveness  that I feel  um  I've never put it in those terms in my  head wow I got chills  it's like I don't want to paint her  negatively I don't want people to think  of her negatively yes but the truth is  tough stuff  [Applause]  yeah I  it took me a long time to accept that my  mom  was not perfect let alone abusive like  it went in baby steps to to put these  pieces of the puzzle together and to  recognize the reality of the pain that  I'd suppressed for decades at that point  you know